so
the way it all ended was greg
at the end of the war okay his dementia
was setting in and he wasn't
making good decisions his son joe
joey who's my godson i stood up for him
at confirmation
winds up getting in the drug business
okay uh
and i'll backpedal that a little bit and
tell you how we all how the club
went downhill but joey was now in the
drug business
and i guess there was a corner that he
claimed was his
and somebody else was selling there so
he went with a baseball bat
the guy pulls out a gun so he leaves he
comes back to the house
he tells his father his father calls me
i was home
it takes me five minutes eight minutes
to get there depending on lights you
know in brooklyn
i drive to the house and he tells me
what happened
so i said all right i know the kid mike
i'll go talk to him i know who he's
talking about
we go to the corner he's not there
anymore he probably knew something was
coming
but before we go joey has a gun i took
the gun from i put in the
in the glove compartment and i locked it
i said we're not going to kill the kid
okay your father asked me to talk to him
and straighten this out this kid was
becoming a little nutty he wanted to be
like like his father
you know yeah he's got that comment
misled to be right
be the grim reaper so we go looking
15 20 minutes he's not around i said
let's
let's go home i go back i tell greg i
says i think it's best anyway
i said let everybody cool down we'll
find them tomorrow
cooler heads he agreed with me he says
yeah
that that i think you're right i go home
i'm not home
one minute i don't have my clothes i'm
getting
ready to get on and like the phone rings
and it's linda
screaming on the phone panicking like
like a lunatic
she thinks joey got killed greg's shot
she just i'll be right there she's
telling me she needs me come over come
over please
i get in the car i drive back on the way
i passed the block where this kid lives
there's unmarked cars there's police
cars
ambulances fire department i mean it's a
crime scene
i go around the long way go to the house
i
get to the house the car that i was in
has bullet holes all over it joey's
friend who was
who was in the car with me also with joe
he was sitting in the back
joey was sitting next to me is in the
back seat
gasping trying to get a breath of life
every once in a while
he's dying i go upstairs into the house
greg is on the phone he has a scotch in
front of him
he's got a towel he got his eye shot out
okay and he's telling the parole people
because we were already
he was arrested and was given bail
which is the biggest the biggest foss in
the history of mankind because
no mob guys get bail nobody
they gave him bail and he had the
bracelet on so they were calling this is
the br your alarm went off you were
further than 50 feet from your house
and he's denying it i never left i've
been here the whole time
now i got to bring him to the hospital
okay what do you mean when you say he
got his eye shot out oh he went there
with joey joey was probably still
breaking his chops we got to get this
guy we can't let him do this he pulled a
gun on me
and probably i i knew he used to get
under as far as skin he's all right you
want to kill him let's go [ __ ] do it
you know just like that just let's go
so he goes they were waiting they were
in front of the house and there's about
eight guys soon as greg gets out he
starts shooting
they're all shot they're opening up a
shot this kid's in the back seat he gets
hit in the head
joey runs he runs in the driveway i
heard a kid hit him in a garbage pail or
something
so he wound up surviving and the father
gets his eye shot out
so i got to bring him to the hospital
there's four or five hospitals in
brooklyn that i could bring him to
he insists on going to the hospital that
saved him mount sinai and then
so i got to go through toll boots with
cops it's the days when the cops manned
them
at the tunnels i gotta drive through
manhattan
with this guy dying in the car and i do
it
i'm so i was loyal to a fault back then
oh the kid's still in the back seat
no no no we took him i took him in my
car greg big greg he's got a guy he's
gonna die he's gonna bleed to death
right
so i walk into the hospital with him and
the nurse comes
and she says oh my god what happened i
said he fell in the yard i think a pipe
went in his eye
so she wheels them in they wheel them in
the back they put them on the gurney
they wheel them in the room
she gives me paperwork to fill out
she comes back out she says you stay
right here
i know she saw a bullet so when she
walks away
i go to the door i open it i says greg i
gotta go
he's laying there like this he goes like
this to me thumbs up
that's the last time i seen him in the
free world really
yeah that was the last show because now
they locked him up and they he couldn't
get bail
again and they had to leave him in
reich's island for a while which is a
jungle but they had the best aids unit
because of all the junkies in there
and a few months later i got arrested uh
you know uh they just rounded everybody
up from the war
they had guys talking uh four or five
guys flipped
call my cesa akan so yeah the first one
to flip
and call a big meeting and at that
meeting everybody got arrested
except him so i mean that's the
treachery and the back stabbing is
there's no there's no parameters it's
just
it's uh uh mind-boggling how the [ __ ]
did he survive getting shot in the eye
with aids and everything yep yeah and
then the
bullet like what well here's what
happened here's what they said
it didn't go in this way okay it must
have deflected off the car and went in
this way
so it didn't penetrate deep into the
brain okay right
yeah so yeah
yeah both exactly exactly so but he was
running out of
his nine lives you know the aids was
gonna eventually now being in prison he
was
certainly not gonna you know survive you
don't get good medical attention in
there yeah
you know everybody wants to call people
rats and things like that but
i always say there's a lot of different
ways to break that rule
okay some guys uh cop out and admit
things
that are hurting the next wave of
defendants
that happened on my case where guys came
in they admitted there was a war
they admitted they were part of the
colombo family they don't have to prove
that anymore
these guys just admitted it so that
becomes evidence against you
okay but they got their reasonable deal
and they were happy
uh john gotti talking on the tips the
way he did and being flamboyant
and being in the public eye the way he
was all the time
that's not a good thing you know uh
and then other guys do it like my boss
did the smartest way of all
just be partners with an fbi agent your
whole career you'll never get arrested
and that's what happened with him
wow yeah he sold his own son out greg jr
who i'm uh still very friendly with
he did 33 years greg jr and when the
father
died he did a deathbed confession
and he saved other people he didn't put
me
or his son as part of the deadbed
confession
exonerating us so this yeah
yeah and is there stuff that he could
have said that would have
exonerated he could have said that uh
all i did was drive him places
he was my driver he didn't know anything
about the hits
it's what he did for ali boy persico uh
who was the boss
of the big boss of the family carmine
persico's son
and while i was away ali boy told me
that him and his father knew about greg
for the last 20 years so knew about him
talking to them
yeah yeah yeah and then i found out
later on there was an actual case
uh from one of the attorneys on our case
that i i'm friends with now
way after there was a
a very big tax indictment okay
and about eight of the guys heavyweights
in the family were all indicted
greg was one of them so they all show up
to the first arraignment
and it gets delayed you know they always
put it off
for weeks they come back to the next one
they're all there except greg they have
to delay it again
a few weeks later they show up again
no greg the fourth time
they show up no greg they throw the case
out
okay so those guys junior persico was on
that case
so he had to know something but
either he felt he helped us so what's
the problem
right plus they knew he could kill
without having a problem they're never
gonna arrest him so they had him doing a
lot of work over the years
plus he was an enormous earner so all
those things
they they gave him a pass for having a
uh being partners with
an fbi agent
you